بدايه فتره العلاج
تمريض يتحسن
بشكل واضح للاخرين
بس في التجربه الذاتيه
من يرتفع نشاطه ارتفاع داخل موجوده
[موسيقى]
حالات حالات
اهلا هذا فنجان من ثمانيه وانا عبد الرحمن
ابو مالح صح النفسيه من اهم المواضيع اللي
احرصها على الحديث عنها لانها على قدر
اهميتها الا ان الاهتمام فيها ضعيف من
جانب الحكومات والناس انفسهم وهو مكان صعب
هو غير محسوس وهذا يزيد تعقيده الناس لا
تفهم ما تجهل وينتج عن هذا سوء في تصور ما
هي ادارهته وتتركم هذه الصور والتجارب
وتزيد بعد الناس عنا اليوم اذا قلت مستشفى
اشهار ما تشتي في بالك الا كل صوره سلبيه
ممكن تتخيلها حتى انا مستشفى الامل ايه
تغير اسمها الى مركز اراده همم محاوله
تغيير الصوره الذهنيه عنه ضيفي في هذه
الحلقه الدكتور ياسر الدباغ قائد
الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه للصحه النفسيه في
السعوديه هذه عن الصح النفسيه على عده
ارتفاعات على بعد 30,000 قدم ننزل الى
10,000 قدم وننزل الى الارض
وطبعا بحكم خبره الطويله داخل وخارج
السعوديه وتنوع مناصبه لتعطيه هذه النظره
الشامله والقريبه من المريض فالحلقه تعطيه
جوانب تاريخيه وشموليه وكذلك خاصه بعلاقه
الطبيب
قبل ان نبدا نشاركنا اسماء ومواضيع
تقترحون على فنجان على بريد البرنامج
فنجان 8 دوت كوم
لنبدا
كنت يعني في نقاش عن الحلقه الاولى
الواحد يحتاج يعني مثلا في الاكتئاب انه
الحبوب وكذا
يعني هل هو فعلا اليوم صرنا نعيش جزء من
الرفاه انه صرنا نهتم
للصحه النفسيه
وصلنا ندور عليها وما كانت موجوده اول كان
الناس يعيشون تمام اليوم نحن بدنا ندور
على امراض جديده ونكتشفها ونعالجها
فهل هو جزء من الرفا ولا فعلا احنا نحتاج
هذا العلاج
[ضحك]
ما هي فقط
اخذه من التراب النفسي
الصح النفسيه
هو هي الرفاع النفسي
يعني المرض لا يكفي عشان الواحد يقول
الانسان انه صحيح
بس الرفاه
يعني
النفسيه بالذات
مرتبطه
بعوامل كثيره جدا
يعني
بعضها مؤثر بشكل مباشر في الصحه العامه
غير الصحيحه النفسيه
بس اغلبها مش مرتبط بالصحه العامه
غير مباشره
الرفاها النفسيه حقيقه ما هي
رفاهيه
بالمعنى الشائع
اعفاء النفسيه ضروره
هي الوضع الطبيعي للانسان
الى ايجاده
من المهم ان الانسان يكون قادر على انه
اييي
استمتع
بنشاطات حياتي بشكل عام
يكون قادر على تكوين علاقات
مفيده مثريه لحياته
يكون الاعاقات اللي فيها استقرار
يكون قادر على انه يعمل بحيث انه يشعر
بانه
مفيد للاخرين
وقادر على انه
يسري حياته يسري العلاقات اللي في حياته
قادر على الحب
قادر على
انه
يشعر بدرجه من
الطمانينه
لان بان الامور في حياته ماشيه في اتجاه
هو رضي عنه
نوع من القناعه في مجالات عديده في الحياه
يعني مثلا الان
يعني في تربيه الاطفال وفي العلاقات اللي
ما بين الاباء والاولاد
اصبحت اليوم مقننه ويخافون لا تضرب لا
تسويه لانجليش عشان لا يتعاقد نفسه
بينما مثلا في الماضي كلنا كلنا ننضرب
مافينا الا العافيه
طيب يعني انت جمله ما فينا الا العافيه ان
تاكد منها
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
بالمناسبه
في دقائق ولا في ثواني ولا في ساعات ولا
في ايام ولا في اسابيع
نفسي اخرج
شهور سنوات
الوطني
[موسيقى]
يعني هل فعلا الممثله السعوديه يعاني من
مشاكل نفسيه هو سؤال بيقترض انه ممكن انه
مجتمع ما يعاني من مشاكل نفسيه
لا يمكن
الاضطراب النفسي جزء من طبيعه الانسان
اللي اقيمت في المملكه
ويعني اعطتنا معلومه جزئيه عن
انتشار الاضطرابات النفسيه في المملكه
في مرحله عمريه معينه وفي فتره زمنيه
معينه
انا ما كنت من الفريق اللي قام بالدراسه
بس يعني
بشاركهم في بعض التحليلات الثانويه
كثيره جدا
يعني دليل التشخيص اللي بنستخدمه
في ما يزيد عن 300 اضطراب واذا اخذنا كل
الرموز الفرعيه كل التراب ممكن يكون له
اشكال ثانويه ممكن يزيد عن 6 تشخيص
المسح الوطني درس 16 فقط
ما في امكانيه انه نغطي كل حاجه في اي
دراسه
طب لما تقرا النتائج كانت مثلا انه
للطلبات الاكثر شيوعا في السعوديه مثلا
تراب قلق الانفصال اضطراب نقص الانتباه
وفرط الحركه اييه الرهاب الاجتماعي
الوسواس القهري هذه الاغلب الاكثر انتشارا
ليش لسه هذه النوع من
الاضطرابات هي الاكثر انتشارا في المجتمع
هذه الاكثر انتشارا من الاضطرابات اللي
درست في الدراسه
الدراسه ما قدرت انها زمان
كل دراسه بحثيه لها حدودها
يكون فيها فيديوهات
[موسيقى]
ممتازه جدا لكنها كانت صعبه واجهت صعوبات
كثيره
[موسيقى]
يعني اخذت وقت طويل عشان تنتهي
مصنع تغير علينا يعني بحجم معين
وفتى عمريه ما بين عمر 15 الى 65
[موسيقى]
فبالتالي كان بالضروره لابد النوت تنحذفه
ومع ذلك
اللي كانت التركيز عليها اكثر هي اللي
اضطرابات
سهل في حجم العين
وطريقه الان المنهج الدراسه انها تلقط
تلتقط في احصائيين
ليش
يعني الطرفات معينه منتشره اكثر من من
غيرها معظم هذه الاضطرابات لها درجات
انتشار المتشابهه عالميا
يعني لما يقول لك انه فرقه الانتباه 8%
النسبه العالميه تتراح من سته الى 10%
يعني وجود درجه معينه من الانتشار
مش بالضروره معناها انه هذا الشيخ خاص
بالمملكه نحنا يهمنا نعرف التفاصيل هذه
لانه حتى لو في فرق واحد في الميه مثلا عن
المعدل العام او 2% هالمعدله يعني هذا كله
اثر على
يعني
الخدمات المقدمه هيكون له اثارها على
توجيه الموارد البشريه والماليه
يعطيك صوره عن المشهد الصحيح في السعوديه
مثلا
80% من السعوديين اللي شخصيا حاله حالته
المجتمع اليوم بسرعه عامه
هذه 80% اكثر حتى شويه من 80% بالنسبه
للطلبات
بالنسبه للطلبات اللي هي
شكلها بالنسبه اقل من كده
يعني خفيفه والمتوسطه الشده
في نسبه اعلى من الناس
بحاجه الى خدمه
يجب علينا كل ما ازدادت حده التراب كل ما
كان
رغبته في العلاج اكثر لكن كذلك ممكن تكون
المساله انه كل ما ازدادت حده التراب كل
ما اتقلت قدره الانسان على انه يسعى
للعلاج او قلت
درجه استفساره بوجود الحاجه
ايوه
ايش الاشياء الثانيه اللي لها علاقه
بالمستفندي اخر صوره عامه عن المجتمع
النفسيه يعني وين احنا من العالم في مشهد
الصحيه
[موسيقى]
انتشار الخدمات
ممكن يكون افضل بكثير من من
يعني
الان في 19 مستشفى الصحه النفسيه او علاج
الادمان
وفي مقدمين
هذه المتابعه لوزاره الصحه في مقدمين
للعنايه في القطاع الخاص في القطاعات
العسكريه وانقطاع التعليمي
[موسيقى]
لكن مع مع كل ذلك
الحقيقي
[موسيقى]
عدد
المختصين في المجال يعني هو تقريبا
العامل الاساسي للحد من
زياره الخدمه او انتشارها هي القوى
العامله
الطب النفسي والعلاج النفسي يعتمد على
الناس
[موسيقى]
القوى العامله عندنا فيها نقص كبير جدا
يعني انا طبيب نفسي تخصص الفرعي طب نفس
اطفال ومراهقين
المدينه الي كنت اعمل فيها في في كندا كان
في مدينه العاصمه
عدد سكانها 750 الف
فيها مستشفى للاطفال
مستشفى الاطفال هدف في
الصحه النفسيه
المستشفى الولايه
المجموعه السكان اللي يغطيها
يغطيها تقريبا مليون ونصف
مليون ونصف
في لهم طابق كامل في المستشفى
وفي مستشفى اخر تنوين للمراهقين فقط
في نفس المدينه
المستشفى فقط المستشفى هذا اللي انا كنت
شغال فيه كان في 23 طبيب نفسي اطفال
طويله
نسبه الاطفال المراهقين من السكان هناك
19%
نسبه الاطفال والمراهقين عندنا في
السعوديه 30%
هنشوفها الان في نتيجه التعداد الجديد لمن
تطلع في الشهر هذا ان شاء الله
بس هذا المتوقع
عندنا
حائط في جراحين القلب
يعني جراح القلب
[موسيقى]
المملكه كلها
37 مليون نفر
فيها 50 طبيب نفسي اطفال
سعوديه ممكن تجيب كوادر خارج السعوديه
هتقولي حتى تستخدمهم البلد ثاني كيف
الطلب
[موسيقى]
عالي في كل مكان
لما يكون عندك
التركيب السكانيه
الفئه العمريه العامله
اطفال يا اما متقاعدين
الفعل هذه الفئه هيكون صعب جدا انها تغطي
احتياجات الجميع
وخاصه عندنا يعني فتره طويله من الزمن كان
نسبه العماله بين النساء منخفضه
يعني حتى الفئه العمريه العامله كانت النص
تقريبا اه
الان بدا الوضع يتغير
كذلك بدات التركيب السكانيه تتغير شويه
يعني
[موسيقى]
نسبه الاطفال بتقل نسبه المسنين بتزيد
وبالتالي مع مرور الوقت خلال 20 30 سنه
القادمه
هتبدا تقترب من التركيب السكانيه الموجوده
في كثير من الدول العربيه
وهيبدا يكون اسهل انه نغطي بعض هذه
الفجوات بس
المساله صعبه مثلا مش سهله ابدا لن اغطي
هذا الفجوات
وخاصه اذا كان الهدف عندنا انه نغطيها
بقوه عامله هذا الجوده
[موسيقى]
باستمرار المواكبه هي اساس النجاح ولاننا
رواد المستقبل الرقمي نوظف خبراتنا
وقدراتنا لنمكن نبتكر في تبني احدث
التقنيات وتوفير الحلول بكفاءه سلوشن سبا
[موسيقى]
ولما نتكلم عن الكوادر هنا ناخذ اللي كنت
تقصد في الارقام
الاطباء النفسيين
والاطباء
بالنسبه للمجموعه الاطباء النفسيين في
السعوديه
في بدايه
اعتقد في 2020
كان في مسجلين في هيئه التخصصات الصحيه
1100 الطبيب
نطاق التخصص طب النفسي
بس من 1100 هذول يعني
400 فقط
او اطباء مقيمين اطباء تحت التدريب
طبعا
النسبه 400 هذول هي هم اللي نقدر نعتبرهم
اطباء نفسيين
عالميا لما بيقارنه
بيقارنه الحاصلين على البول فقط
[موسيقى]
في نقص كبير بالنسبه للكوادر اللي هي على
درج العالم
قراءه معلومه عن
المعالج نفسيه
طبيب نفسي ممكن يكون معالج نفسي
في السعوديه
البريد الدرب بينما في امريكا
عايطلب انه ياخذ ماجستير
و ثلاثه ثلاثه
2019 تقريبا
[موسيقى]
وجدوا ان الحاصلين على الماجستير
والدكتوراه في
علم نفس الكلام
اللي بيمارسوا في القطاع الصحي مفروض تكون
نفس الارشادي كذلك مناسب اذا حصل على درجه
كافيه
[موسيقى]
لكن
185 شخص
عارف 2019 زائد واكيد عن كده
بس يعني
نقص الحديد
في
التصنيف
يعني المساله
معقده اني اعطيك اجابه فيها ابيض واسود
لكن الحاجه
عاليه جدا
وانا محتاج فعلا اني اقدم خدمه
لو ما قدمت اي خدمه معناته ما يتصل فائده
لاحد
لو قدمت خدمه ضعيفه قد تصل
كثير من الضرائب قد يحصل وقد يحصل ضرر
فاذا قدرنا انه نقلنا الوضع لو استطعنا
انه نوجد
اليه للاشراف على اللي ما حصل على تدريب
بحيث انه
اللي تاهيلهم منخفض
ممارستهم تكون تحت الاشراف
من الناس عندهم قدره عاليه على يعني خبره
عاليه
وتاهيل عالي
هيكون في امكانيه هنا انهن
نقلل باكثر ممكن من الضرر
وما نحرم الناس
الاهلي فيها صعوبه فيها صعوبه لانه
القائدرين على الاشراف اللي عندهم مؤهلين
للاشراف قليلين او غير متوفرين
يعني او صاحب الوصول
مستشفى في الرياض نقصد فيه الامل
في الطائف
يعني في الخاص
طبيعه الحال بالنسبه للمستشفيات المتخصصه
في الصحه النفسيه
حولها هذه السنه
جزء من
الاشكاليه التاريخيه في
تكوين الخدمات النفسيه عندنا
انه نحن بدانا متاخر
دخل معنا دخل يعني احنا كده والحديثه اصلا
بس قصدي متاخر مقارنه بالدول
الاخرى
[موسيقى]
يعني مستشفى الصحه النفسيه في شعار في
الطائف
حسب ما اتذكر عام 1952
هذا العقد من الزمن
هو العقد اللي بدات الدول الغربيه في تقفل
المساحات النفسيه
حركه اسمها
ازاله المؤسسه
احنا بدانا من حيث ابتدا مش من حيث
وابتدينا بانه نفصل صح النفسيه عن
الصحه النفسيه
طبعا الحركه اللي هم جابوا فيها كانت يعني
مدفوعه بعوامل
سياسيه محليه واقتصاديه
كانت مستعجله جدا
فتفع ثمن
بعض
ما مشيت بسلاسه
[موسيقى]
في المجتمع
للناس اللي خرجوا من المصحات
انه يوجد دعم اجتماعي كافي
فبالتالي يعني صار فيه
نسبه من التشرد والفقر يعني مشاكل
اجتماعيه كبيره
ادم تقديم الخدمات
الفئه
بس كان ممكن انه يعني نتعلم من هذا الدرس
ونسوي الامور بشكل مختلف
[موسيقى]
احنا اتجهنا الى انه لفتره طويله استمرينا
يعني
عقود انه نفصل
خدمات الصحه النفسيه عن
خدمات الصحه
يزيد الوصله
محتاج المساله
تواجدها كان صعب
يقول عامله كانت مش موجوده كان صعب انك
انت تستقبل القوى العامله التي تحتاجها
كان لازم تبتعد كان لازم تدرس كلها
بتنفتح مستشفيات كافيه تغطي احتياج الناس
اصلا مستحيل المستشفيات
الناس
كبير جدا
لما يكون العدد الاسره المتاحه محدود جدا
في مستشفى معزول عمليه المجتمع وما بتقدر
انك انت تستخدم الاسره المتاحه هذه
الا للحالات الشديده
[موسيقى]
بالضروره
ما حد دخل الحالات اللي هي يعني ممكن
تستفيد من التنوين بس انه في حالات يعني
اشد منها
فبالتالي بيكون منومين فيها حالات جديده
فعلا
بس سهل جدا انه
سمعت انه هذه المستشفيات
بين قوسين المجانين انها تكون منتشره يعني
كذلك لانها معزوله بعيد عن المجتمع بعيد
عن المجتمع الصحي بعيد عن المعايير الطبيه
اللي بنشوفها في المستشفيات العامه سهله
جزء من الوصمه المرتبطه الان
بالاطربات النفسيه
ويمكن يكون الجزء الاكبر مرتبط بجوده
الخدمه
الناس تحس انه
في مشكله في الخدمه في مشكله في المقدمه
في مشكله في مكان تقديم الخدمه
والشكل المثالي
بعد الفصل
المستشفيات تكون ضمن
المستشفى العادي
التنويم
في
تحت يعني الطب النفسي
الطريقه للممثله هي انها تكون في مستشفى
عام زي ما في
انابرلي للاورام عنابر الجراحه عنابر
يعني
امراض باطنيه يكون في عنبر
الاضطرابات النفسيه
واحيانا نكون انا متخصصه
اراده ولا اشهار نفسك
الصوره النبطيه المنتشره في المجتمع اسوء
من الواقع
لكن الواقع يعني قدامه مساحه كبيره من
التحسن علشان يصل الى
المعيار اللي يعني نطحنه
ولما نقول انسان مجنون هل في احد مجنون
يعني هي كلمه مجنون
فيها درجه ملل الاشكال هي كلمه
تاريخيا مرتبطه بانه قبل ما يكون في علم
يفهمنا
مش طبيعه الاضطرابات الشديده الحاده
كان في ربط بين هذا الاضطرابات وبين مثل
الجن
لكن
يعني الان الكلمه اتوقع غير مناسب ابدا
انه نستخدمها
لان يعني ما تصف اللي نعرفه
الان يعني
اعطيك مثال همم لو كل الامراض الجلديه
سميناها جرب
هل هذا شيء مناسب
يعني تخصص كامل
ويمكن يعني انه الشخص اللي ما يعرف انواع
الامراض الجلديه يسميها كلها بنفس الاسم
كلها
يعني
تاريخيا سابق
المعلومات اللي عندنا حاليا
ومرسخ للرسمه
اليوم وفقا لمعرفه وتطور العلم من نفسي في
احد مجنون
في الطلبات بتخلي
الانسان غير قادر على انه يفرق بين
الواقع
وبين
ظواهر تحدث في عقله
هذه بنسميها طلبات دهنيه
[موسيقى]
وبالتالي بيكون درجه الصفصاره بالواقع
منخفضه
ربما يكون تكون منخفضه الى درجه بحيث انه
غير قادر على اتخاذ قرارات
سليمه وهو في تلك الحاله من الشده
بمعنى اللي يمكن المنظور الشرعي يكون
مرفوع عن القلم في هذه اللحظه
لكن اسميه مجنون
ممكن بالعلاج تتعالج اكيد
الناس اللي كنا نشوفهم مثلا
في ذكر في القريه في واحد يعني كان ممكن
معروف انه مجنون
راح لعياده نفسيه كان ممكن ان يكون انسان
عادي
بس لا تختلف من من مريض لاخر
بعض الاضطرابات الذهنيه
او تيجي على شكل النبات
بعضها مزمنه وحتى بعد المزمنه تيجي فيها
نوبات تزيد فيها حده المرض وفترات تقل في
حده المرض
اضطرابات المزمنه في نسبه من الناس بيصلوا
الى درجه عاليه من القضاء على الاعراب
والعوده الى الى مستوى وظيفي
قريب من الطبيعي او طبيعي
وفي نسبه بيكون في اثر مسمن للمراه لكن
قادرين على انهم يؤدوا اداء مقبول
اجتماعيا وفي نسبه المرض ماثر عليهم بشكل
جديد بشكل مزمن
كل اضطراب يعني بتنقسم يعني نتائج العلاج
في الى هذه النتائج الاضطرابات المزمنه
بتنقسم في الى احدى هذه الفئات الثلاثه
تقريبا
طيب
اليوم هذا نتكلم يعني اخذنا صوره عامه عن
القطاع العام
وانت قلت انه يوم تكلمنا عن اراده واشهر
انهم لا يسالون بعيدين عن المعمول
المستشفيات
الى المامول لانه
صور عن التعليمي ولا في العسكري او
المستشفيات اللي ما عليها نفس الدرجه
الضغط الشديد
اللي على مستشفيات وزاره الصحه
قادر ان يكون فيها نسبه من المختصين
للمرضى اعلى نسبه من
التمريض
يعني على كفاء عاليه
بتكون اعلى عنده نسبه من
اخصائيين النفسيين الحاصلين
يعني مكثف بتكون اعلى لانه
الضغط اللي عليهم اقل الفئه السكانيه اللي
بيخدموها اصغر
الان اييه مستشفيات وزاره الصحه
في ما يخص الصحه النفسيه تخدم حوالي
78 الى 80% من الشعب
بين المستشفيات القطاعات العسكريه
والامنيه
والحرس
المستشفيات الجامعيه
الخاص
النسبه والتناسب في الطلب
المعرضين له والخدمه القادرين انهم
يقدموها
الضغط عالي جدا جدا على مستشفيات وزاره
الصحه
[موسيقى]
يعني وهذا جزء من
سبب الدهان انه يوجد استراتيجيه بعيده
المدى
بحيث انه نقدم خدمه فيها كفاءه عاليه
بجوده افضل
وتصل الى نسبه اعلى من الناس انه الان
احنا غير قادرين نصل الى النسبه الى
نطنحلها من الناس اللي هم بحاجه الى
العراق
الخدمه بجوده جيده او بكفاءه عاليه
[موسيقى]
كيف
يعني وصلت الاسره
العيادات التنويم والاسره في القطاع الخاص
منخفض جدا
لانه متغير يعني من خلال السنوات القادمه
لا يعني في بعض المستشفيات بتمون في الصحه
النفسيه لكن
الاغلبيه يعني
ما بتقدم على الخدمه وبكون الاعتماد على
العيالات الخارجيه بشكل شكرا بس ليش قله
الاثر
القضاء الخاص
العوامل المؤثره على هذا الشيء كثير جدا
الناحيه الربحيه المباشره
في
وانا باركز على كلمه مباشر
قليله
يعني
[موسيقى]
اللي بيقدم خدمه صحيه في القطاع الخاص
يربح من التدخلات الجراحيه
ما يربح من تنويم مريض نفسي
وجود مريض في المستشفى
مقلف
والمريض النفسي ممكن نحتاج الى فتره طويله
في المستشفى
في العاده اطول من
يعني المرضى المنومين في الاقسام الاخرى
يعني صاحب
المستشفى يمكن ما يجد جدول المريض
ثانيه للتغطيه التامينيه منخفضه الان
بتزيد
يعني جهود كثيره بذلت عشان نزيل الضغط
التامينيه للطلبات النفسيه
يعني الحمد لله قاعده بتزيد
اكثر لكن
كثير من الناس
الليله في المستشفى سواء
نفسي ولا في قسم باطني ولا فيك يعني
الاسعار متقاربه
غاليه غاليه جدا
الناس اللي يقدر يتحملوا المبالغ
بس انا قلت لك في البدايه انه الربح
المباشر كده قليل
قليل جدا حديثه
التخصصات الاخرى
خاصه ان انت بتقدم الخدمه للجوده نوع
الربح منخفض
ولكن العائد الاقتصادي عالي جدا
عالي جدا بحيث انه اعلى من معظم التخصصات
الاخرى
الان لو
اقتصاد
نا ريال واحد في في علاج
الاكتئاب
يرجع للاقتصاد العام خمسه ريال
دفعنا ريال واحد في التدخل المبكر للتوحد
على مدى 50 سنه من عمر الطفل هذا
يرجع للاقتصاد اربع ايام
لو دفعنا ريال واحد لعلاج الادمان
يرجع الاقتصاد 13 ريال
العائد الاقتصادي العام كبير جدا لانه
الاثر الاقتصادي للاضطراب النفسي ضخم مش
فقط على الشخص على الشخص على ضوء الشخص
على
يعني كل المحيطين بالشخص على المجتمع
ردما انه هذه العائد واضح العلاج
غير مكلف ايه
مكلفه اذا كانت تنوين
حتى لو انت نظرت الى علاج مثلا علاج نفسي
طويل الامل
ممكن اشوف المريض ثلاث مرات في الاسبوع
للسنوات
في
استراليا المذكر
انه تحليل نفسي هناك والعلاج التحليلي
متغطي
العلاج التحليلي بيكونوا في الخمسينات من
عمره
الان نفترض مثلا معدل فتره العلاج 10
سنوات
ولا هو في الاربعينات
فساتين الستينات مش كده
العلاج كان احتياجهم للقطاع الصحي اقل من
احتياجهم في العشر سنين قبل العلاج
ال 10 سنين اللي بعد العلاج اقل من مكان
في العشر سنين
الكفاءه الاقتصاديه للعلاج عاليه جدا
والعائد الاقتصادي
[موسيقى]
بس بطبيعه الحال
ما فيها
العائد السريع المباشر الان انا لو
بسوي عمليه جراحيه
هدفع مبلغ كبير
والمساله تنتهي العمليه تاخذ لها
ساعات بالكثير يمكن اكثر يمكن اقل
حاجات في المستشفى يومين يمكن اكثر يمكن
اقل
وانتهى الموضوع
القيمه المقدمه بشكل اوضح
ولكن حقيقه مثل
اكثر تعقيدا من كده بكثير
يعني قبل الفجر
[ضحك]
الاضطرابات النفسيه تزيد من احتمال الوفاه
تقريبا كلها بتزيد من احتمال الوفاء
هذا غير الامتحان
نتكلم عن
النقص في عمر الانسان
يعني
الاضطرابات الشديده كذلك يعني اثرها ضخم
جدا
والسكري من ناحيه اثرها على
العمر المتوقع انه انسان نعيشه
الحصان يقلل من عمر الانسان في المتوسط ما
بين 13 الى 20 سنه
رفع الجوده
الطب النفسيه
اول حاجه يعني العوامل اللي بتقلل من وصول
الناس
للخدمات الاوامر الي بتقلل من الميول اللي
بيدرسوا في المجاعه لانه متخصصه في الصحه
النفسيه
والحوامل الاقتصاديه التي تكلمنا عنها
المباشر
مؤثر في كل مكان في العالم
الوصمه موجوده في كل مكان في العالم
درجات متفاوته من مكان لاخر
ايش السؤال
ايش اللي يخلي
الانسان اللي بيدرس طبيب نفسي اساسا
ايش اللي يخلي انسان يفكر انه يدرس علم
النفس وتخصص النفس
ايش اللي يخلي الانسان يشعر بانه بيعاني
انه معناته هذه ممكن انه تستفيد من
تدخل العلاجي يمكن هذه هي الاسئله اللي
محتاجها مش مش موجوده لانه في كل مكان في
العالم في نفسه في الخدمات النفسيه
بترجع متفاوته
والعوامل اللي بتاثر
عوامل كثيره جدا احنا عندنا في المجتمع في
كار معينه عن الاضطرابات النفسيه يمكن
وفهم اجتماعي
بتمنع الناس انها تحصل عليها
يعني
وصلت النفسيه
كان كنا بنتكلم عن الجنون كلمه الجنون هل
طبيب نفسي الدكتور المجانين
الاخصائي يعني وهكذا هذه وصفه
قاعد قاعد بتقل
خاصه في الاجيال الصغيره
الدرجه التعرض الانسان اللي المعلومه
ولكن
مازال في
وصفه مرتبطه بالخدمه نفسها واسمه مرتبطه
بمقدمين الخدمه باماكن تقديم الخدمه
كذلك في صعوبه
احساس بانه
يعني من من ناحيه
ايديولوجيا
انه
الاضطرابات النفسيه
او
قله ايمان
مو لازم نكون يعني ممكن نجوى ايمان
شيء باراده الشخص انه انه يغيره
سهل على الانسان انه
يفكر بطريقه مختلفه انه يشعر بمشاعر
مختلفه
هذا نوع من التفكير
منتشر في كل مكان
وفي ثقافات معينه اكثر من غيرهم
الثقافات الجميله للتفكير الجامعي
كذلك
تشعر انه اللي يصيب شخص يصيب المجموعه
ممكن انه قوم تمنع بنتها انها تشوف طبيب
نفسي علشان
اختها تتزوج
انه لو العريس عرف انه والله اخت العروسه
وبعدين احاول ان يحصل الخدمات ما بحصله
خدمات جيده او الخدمات سمعتها سيئه
او صعبه
بيكون لها هذه الاثار
اليوم في فهم اكبر واهتمام اكبر بس احنا
النفسيه في الشباب والشباب اليوم يشكلون
بالنسبه لاكبر من المجتمع
يعني جزء من المشاكل الاجتماعيه انتهت
يعني خلينا على جنب لا تدخل على هذه هذه
نهائيه
هلا اعرفهم اللي موجودين على الانستغرام
متى اروح مع يعني علاج السلوكي يكون
المعرفه السلوكي فاسئله كثير يعني صحيح اه
هو بشكل عام
من المفترض انه
المخصص في المجال
اللي انت تستطيع توصل له
اذا مارس
بامانه مهنيه وبجوده
يوجهك التوجيه الصحيح اذا انت بحاجه انك
تشوف مختص اخر
لو انت شفت او بحاجه الى تداخل عده مجالات
علاجيه بمعنى انك انت لو شفت مختص فعلا
والمخص هذا فعلا
يعني
بيمارس بطريقه جديده
ما في ما في وسيله لانك تعرف مسبقا
جوده الشخص الذي انت رايحله
للشخص
واحيانا يكون
الشخص مشهور لسبب من اوله لاخر
لكن هذه السؤال اسمها او حتى الشهره مش هي
اللي فعلا
المختصه اللي بتروح له
خبرتك مع المختصين
الان انت لو رحت المختص فعلا مهني وشرف
انك انت محتاج الى طبيب نفسي هيقول لك
روحي طبيب نفسي
او خلينا نشترك في العلاج انا اقدم لك
جلسات علاجيه انت محتاج كذلك الى علاج
دوائي
الطبيب النفسي اللي ما بيقدم جلسات علاجيه
علاج نفسي ممكن انه يوجه المريض الى وتصلي
العلاج النفسي
اقول له انت محتاج الاثنين او محتاج لعلاج
بالجلسات مش علاج بالدواء اول اثنين او
علاج بالدواء هو المهم وبعدين يمكن خطوه
ثانيه او هو العلاج الاساسي فمثلا تختلف
اختلاف المشكله اللي بيمرني هالشخص
الاضطراب اللي عنده
وقدره
المختص اللي بيشوفه انه يوجهه التوجيه
الصحيح
بس الكلام والله صعب
واحد او شيء عن الاطمئنان
لسمعه
العياده او الدكتور
مو بالضروره صحيحه ممكن يكون اكثرهم شهره
وهو سيء جدا طيب انت عمرك ما شفت طبيب
جلديه
ايش راح تسوي
محتاج انك تشوف طبيب جلديه ممكن اسال ايش
اسوي يقول لي
[موسيقى]
تروح المستشفى وتقول لهم التامينات
كيفيه التامينات العامه
التامين الخاص
كل حاجه
بالنسبه للصحه النفسيه
اقدر اروح بعد اسبوع اقدر اشوف
النت
تنعكسه
اقل وجلسه واحده لانه
ابدا مش صحيح
لا لانه
بدفع انا نسبه بسيطه يعني بدفع شيء جديد
في الطب النفسي اني انا بروح بعد عدد من
الجلسات ابي اشوف
اذا
ينفع اذا هو صح ولا لا ممكن
يعني في في امراض همم يعني في الجسد همم
تاخذ فتره طويله
الطلبات النفسيه بشكل عام تحتاج الى فتره
طويله في العلاج لكن في موقع كثير امراض
مقابله لها في الامراض الجنسيه تاخذ فتره
طويله انت ما راح تشوف النتيجه بشكل سريع
هتاخذ فتره طويله
انك انت تروح الى طبيب قلب
وما تشعر بارتياح
وتفكر اوك يعني هلا عندي اختيارات اخرى
نفس الشيء بيحدث مع طبيب النفسيه
والاخصائي النفسي
[ضحك]
انت تقول
ما بين الجلسه لوحدكم بدها تقريبا ساعه
وتكون تحتاج ما بين ثلاثه الى اربع جلسات
اسبوعيه
لا تقل عن ثلاث سنين وتصل الى 10 سنين هذا
التحليل النفسي
ههه
يعني
غير العلاج التحليلي العلاج التحليلي بكون
مبني على المباد التحليليه ممكن يكون مره
في الاسبوع ممكن يكون مرتين في الاسبوع
[موسيقى]
وفي الفترات اللي هي يكون يبدا فيها
الانسحاب من العلاج ممكن يكون حتى كل
اسبوعين
بس بكل فتره طويله عاده عندنا
[موسيقى]
وفي انواع كثير من العلاج بنسميها احنا
ساكتين
مشتقه كذلك
وهذه بعضها قصيره
[موسيقى]
برضو
جلسه في الاسبوع ممكن ثلاثه او اربعه اشهر
يعني الدراسات اللي يطبقت على كافه انواع
العلاج النفسي من ناحيه
المخرجات
في اداء
وقبول المرضى للنتائج
اكشن
وجدو انه
العلاج نفسي بشكل عام يحتاج الى ما
يعادل حوالي 40 جلسه
لحد قدنا عشان تصل نسبه عاليه من الرضا
ومن العوده
حتى العلاجات اللي هي انواع العلاج اللي
هي صمم انها تكون قصيره الامان
بتنتهي انها تاخذ فتره اطول
على ارض الواقع عشان نصل الى نتائج مرضيه
ممكن في فتره قصيره انك تحقق تحسن
هل تحسن هذا الكافي هل تحسن مرضي
على ارض الواقع بتاخذ الفتره بتاخذ
المساله فتره اطول
في عندنا علاج تحليلي وشنو نوع العلاج
الموجوده
انواع العلاج النفسي الموجوده
يعني مدارس عامه
في تقدر تقسم العلاج النفسي الى علاج فردي
علاج اسري
او ازواج
وعلاج جماعي
كل
الاجسام هذه في مدارس للعلاج النفسي وتحت
كل المدرسه في انواع كثير من العلاج
النفسيه انواع المدارس الرئيسيه همم
المدرسه التحليليه والسكن
المدرسه المعرفيه
المدرسه السلوكيه
هارب بالنسبه
للمدرسه اللي بين شخصين
هذه بالنسبه
العلاج الفردي بالنسبه للعلاج الاسري في
مدارس المختلفه
وحتى هذا المدارس الاربعاء
يعني ما هو معقول انه شخص عنده التهاب في
الرئه انه هو اللي يحدد ايش المضاد الحيوي
اللي يناسبه
اللي اللي
يحدد اللي يناسبك المختص اللي بيشوفك كذلك
جزء من التحديد ايش المتوفر
المختص اللي يشوفك ايش هو مدرب على ايش
يعني بيكون من العوامل اللي بتحدد العلاج
فيكون يعني من البدايه من طبيب الاسره ولا
منهم يوجه
طبيب الاسره ممكن انه بالنسبه
للحالات الشائعه
زي
القلق
الطلبات القلق هي بشكل عام
وخاصه كانت خفيفه او متوسطه ترى بالاكتئاب
وهو متوسطه
كان نفسي
اللي هي بتكون
سهله الوصول لها متوفره
وكل هذا بتكون قصيره تماما
بالنسبه بعدين اذا الشخص محتاج الى التدخل
طبيب نفسي او اخصائي نفسي على ترجع
بالنسبه للمدرسه التحليليه وهذه المدرسه
يعني صعب
انك تمسك عليها شيء صعب انك
تثبتها صعب انك
في هذا الغموض
والنسبيه والسيول العاديه اه
فكيف تشوف اليوم
في ظل هذا المدارس موجوده
مع تقدم العلم اللي بدات يعني تصير اصلا
ممكن غير صحيحه
ههه
انواع اخرى
انا لازم اعرف السلوك
[موسيقى]
العلاج الاسري العلاج
الجمعيه من زمان لكن
عشان الانسان يصبح محل بياخذ يعني تدريب
طويل جدا
بتكلم عنه بشكل اكثر
بالنسبه
لصعوبه النظريات غموضها على الناس
النظريات التحليليه
بطبيعه الحال صعبه
فهمها يحتاج الى طريقه تفكير مختلفه شويه
لانه ما بتتعامل مع الامور اللي هي
[موسيقى]
واصله للوعي بشكل واضح
بتتعامل مع المحركات الداخليه اللي بتحرك
الانسان
وتتعامل مع تكوين العلاقات تتعامل مع
تراكم الخبرات عبر النشاه
عبر حياه الانسان
تعمل مع مراحل النمو النفسي
الهامل مع الرغبات مع الخيالات مع الاحلام
[موسيقى]
الدوافع اللي بتكون غير نوعيه
ما هو منطقي اصلا انها تكون سهله لانها
بتدرس شيء مش معي شيء ما هو محسوس
شيء بنستنبته نتيجه ملاحظات طويله يعني
على مدى فتره الزمنيه طويله
انماط من
السلوك والانفعال وتكوين العلاقات
[موسيقى]
محتاج الى الى عمق كبير ومحتاج الى شفافيه
عاليه ما هو من طبيعه الانسان انه يعرض
نفسه لها
كذلك
عقل الانسان
معقد
عقل الانسان معقد
العقل
طبعا
[موسيقى]
لكن الناتج عن اداء الدماغ
الدماغ
عقد ماده يعرفها الانسان
ما في ماده على وجهها يعني معروفه عند اي
عالم من العلماء عقد من الدماغ البشري
والناتج اداء
الدماغ البشري عقل في غايه التعقيد
فكره بسيطه تفصل لنا سلوك الانسان
في هذا التوقف حدثه المشكله
طيب
النظريات اللي طرحت
بطبيعه حالها زي كل النظريات العلميه
بتحاول انها تفسر توقع هسه من
الظواهر العقليه اللي بنشوفها
ولمن اي نظريه
حتى النظريات اللي بتستخدم في انواع
العلاج النفس الاخرى
تحاول تعمل حاجه زي كده هتدخل في اشياء
وتنجح في اشياء
اللي
يعطيك فكره عن
النظريه هذه جيده
وهل لما نطبقها
بتعطينا نتائج احنا راضيين هنا
كل العوامل هذه تنطبق على نظريات
التحليليه
التحليل النفسي بدا يعني في اواخر القرن
التاسع عشر اخر عقد من القرن التاسع عشر
يعني الان اكثر من 120 سنه
خلال 120 سنه
التحليليه تطورت بشكل كبير جدا
ما في مواقف مكانها
كلها تاثير كبير على
الممارسه الفعليه
بحيث انه الان لو لو فرويد عائش
محارم احنا شغالي
ن
مختلف تماما
يعني
فكره انه
من نظريات هذه
عليها الزمن هي فكره
يعني
مصدرها اشخاص
القديمه في التحليل النفسي
وما تابعه التطور
نتائج الدراسات التحليليه
و20 على فكره يعني نمطيه او نسائيه قديمه
طبعا
المحللين نفسيين مرت عليهم فتره طويله
عند الاخرين انه كانوا ما عندهم ميول
للقيام
بابحاث الفعاليات علاجاتهم ما كان عندهم
كان عندهم درجه من
عدم المرونه
مش كلهم لانه المناظرين كثير خلال 120 سنه
الماضيه ولكن
بعض الممارسين كان ما عندهم درجه من
المرونه في انهم يطوروا افكارهم يطوروا
الوسائل العلاجيه
وهذه ساهمت شويه في
في نشر هذا الفكره المستقيل في النشاط
تستخدم اكثر من المدرسه فمتى تلجا الى
التحليليه ومتى ترجع الى العلاج
حاليا يعني انا الجا للعلاج المعرفي لما
يكون
الهدف الاساسي
اني اقلل من عرب معين
وبشكل سريع
وخاصه في بعض الطلبات
يعني تحتاج فعلا الى الى تدخل منها نوع
على سبيل المثال الوسواس القهري
وسواس القهريب كثير جدا
من
التدخلات المعرفيه السلوكيه بشكل
يعني مؤثر على
جوده حياه الانسان
بشكل عام
الى المنحه التحليلي
لما يكون
الهدف اكبر من مجرد اني اتعامل مع
الفكره هنا
فكره انه لما الانسان
بيجي العياده
لانه حياته سيئه
العياده مش عشان عرض معين
بيجي العياده علشان مش قادر انه يعيش حياه
جديده
فلذلك لما يكون الهدف تحسين حياه الانسان
بشكل عام
انا لازم ننظر الى تكوين شخصيه الانسان
طريقه تكوين علاقاته جوده علاقاته قدرته
على
تحمل الاحباط
قدره الانسان على انه
يتواجد عاطفيا مع الاخرين
مرور بصدامات معينه مؤثره في حياته
يعني امور كثيره اكثر عقيدا من مجرد انه
[موسيقى]
عنده اعراض قلق او عنده اعراض اكتئاب او
عنده ارق في الليل ما بينام
الغالب لما بتكون الصوره هذه واضحه عند
المريض انه
مريض يحتاج انه يشتغل هنا
على نفسه
طيب بالنسبه
العيادات عن بعد او الجلسات عن بعد كيف
ترى مفعولها
انها قابله فعلا للعلاج والناس تساعدنا في
الوصول الى انه نقدر مثلا
اطباء اقل في اليوم صار منطقه الحصول على
اطباء من كل العالم اذا كانت الازمه
الاسره او الاسره ثاني بس اذا ازمه المكان
والبعد والمسافات صارت اليوم تقدر
اليوم نشوف بعض في تطبيقات يعني في
السعوديه عندنا وغيرها من الشركات اللي
موجوده اللي جالسه تحاول
تدخل هذا
الشكل العام
العلاج همم عن بعد له همم ايجابياته
سلبيات
همم في شيء مفقود
لما الانسان ما يكون في الفطور
في شيء مفقود
كذلك بالنسبه لبعض
الحالات محتاجين الى
الفحص جسدي
بعض الاعراض الجانبيه تحتاج الى
الى الطبيب يعني
يفحص المريض بشكل مباشر
الوضع اللي
موجود فيه
المريض
مؤثر على
اللي بيوصل
للطبيب او المعالج النفسي
الوضع اللي موجود فيه الطبيب او الاخصائي
النفسي مؤثر على القاعدين يوصل
للمريض
فلذلك في في عوامل مفقوده
وهذه حقيقه ان يطول شرحها شويه بالنسبه
خاصه في العلاج النفسي
[موسيقى]
ولكن من الممكن
انه العلاج النفسي
وحتى بعد جلسات المتابعه في الطب النفسي
انها تتم عن بعد وتؤدي
يعني
دورها بشكل
بشكل مرضي
مش كل الحلقات اذا
قطعنا انه الخدمه تقدم
بالمعايير الصحيحه
للقياده الصحيحه
والتنظيم الصحيح
الان انا لما اشوف مريض في المستشفى
في العياده
له ملف طبي
معلومات الطبيه
المريض يعرف بالضبط
خصوصيه المريض محفوظه بشكل كامل
وفي سياسات داخليه وفي الانظمه
الطرق للحفاظ على هذه المعلومات وعلى
السريات خصوصيات المرضى
وفي معايير وشروط معينه للتواصل بخصوص هذه
المعلومات
الاشياء هذه قد تكون مفقوده في بعض
يعني بعضها كلها يكون مفقوده في بعض وسائل
تقديم الخدمه عن بعض حاليا
الهيئه اللي بتقدم فيها الخدمه
تكون هيئه مهنيه لما انت تجيني في العياده
ما بيجيني بالبيجامه
كويس ما بتشوفني انا في سيارتي ولا ولا في
غرفه نومي
في
نوع من الاعتماديه على ايش الوضع
اللي هنتقابل فيه
في معرفه
متى وفين وكيف ولمده
اذا كان فيه كلفه علاج كل شيء محدد مسبقا
معروف
ومضمون لحد الان
انا حاليا ماعندي الوسيله اني اضمن انه
التطبيقات اللي بتقدم خدمه عن بعد تحافظ
على المهنيه هذه وتحافظ على كل المعايير
هذه من الامور اللي
العمل الجارحه لانه نوصل الى طريقه بحيث
انه
قدم الخدمه بشكل مهني عن بعد
في بلاد كثيره كان في شيء اسمه بالنسبه
[موسيقى]
الى حد بسيط كان مقدم في السعوديه
بس هذا كان شيء يعني منظم تنظيم عالي
الطبيب بيقدم الخدمه في المستشفى
المريض
العياده صحيح البعد بس انه مش من البيت من
الشارع
مريض في عياده
في مكان مخصص
الغرفه الصوت والصوره فيها
عن المحيط
انه زوجته تدخل عليه وتسمع
المعلومات المحافظ عليها في بنفس الطريقه
في السجل الطبي ااا
بنفس المنهج
واحيانا بيكون في مقدم خدمه في المكان
اللي فيه المريض
يستطيع انه
يدي يعمل المتابعه الطبيعي يعني طبيب اسره
او ممرض او اخصائي يستطيع ان يعمل
المتابعه مع المريض
لتطبيق الخطه العلاجيه
اللي قدمت عن بعد
يعني اجبرتنا على تطبيق خدمه بطريقه اسرع
واسهل
وفي متناول الجميع وتطبيقات وجود الجوال
مكه من التكنولوجيا الان بتمكن اشياء هذه
همم
تكاثرت التطبيقات
وسائل تقديم الخدمه لكن
المعايير المهنيه والجوده
يعني نحتاج ان ندرس نشوف ايش المشاكل اللي
فيها
اليوم في ملف موحد للمرضى في عند وزاره
الصحه
الملف الموحد على وشك انه
يستر
نوحد عباره عن المعلومات الاساسيه
لكل مريض
[موسيقى]
يعني انظمه ال ال
بالعربيات مختلفه
لكن في طرق
للتواصل بينهم بحيث انه المعلومات
الاساسيه
يكون سهل انها
يحصل تبادل لها بمعرف ثابت لكل المريض
مرتبط بهاوي
يحصل على المعلومات الاساسيه
عندما يحتاج انه يوصل لها يعني افترض انا
علاجي في التمام
وانا في زياره اروح للطوارئ ما فينهم وانا
مهم علي مثلا ما عندهم اي معلومه عني
هتكون المعلومات الاساسيه
قادرين انهم يوصلوا لها فبالتالي يقدر انه
يوجه العلاج بهذا الشكل لكن ما هو كل حاجه
في الملف يعني حسب ما افهم المعلومات
الاساسيه فقط
في
المؤسسه اللي انت فيها
بس وزاره
سوريا
لا المعلومات الاساسيه
وسهوله الوصول اليها تخلي من الصعوبه علي
يعني
اي احد من اي مكان انه يقدر على الوصول
الى المعلومات
يعني
انت لما بتروح المستشفى هل اي احد عنده
وصول معلوماتك اللي في المستشفى
معلومات
احنا مجتمعنا مجتمع نختلف عن امريكا في
امريكا يعني مساله البحث عن الناس ما هي
بوارده بس هنا نعرف نحنا مجتمعات
يعني يعرفوا بعض اغلب الناس لبعض زي كيف
هي خلي هذه المساله حساس جدا
طبيب في المستشفى وتقول له الله يخليك سوي
لي تقسي على فلان لانه مقدم على بنتي ههه
لا ما راح تلاقي المعلومات حقك الا عند
ممارس صحي
بحاجه انه يشوف معلوماتك
لو ممارس كده تقسم من عنده يعمل بحث هذه
حقيقه ممكن تعرضوا الجزاء
ما هو
نظريا ممكن انه ممارسه فيك انه بشتغل في
مؤسسه
انت
بتتعالج فيها انه يشوف معلوماتك
لكن حقيقه يعني هذه حتى تصير استلحوله
يعني الان النظام الالكتروني ما بسجل بس
المعلومات اللي دخلت في النظام عنك
[موسيقى]
باي شيء متعلق فيك
انا سال عن البرد القارس
[ضحك]
الله يعطيك العافيه
في الهندسه الصوتيه هذا فنجان احد منتجات
شركه ثمانيه
الانتاج من مدينه الرياض
الاسبوع المقبل
[موسيقى]
الطبيب النفسي
او المعالج نفسي المعالج النفسي او
الطبيعيه يعني سواء الطبيب او معالج لكن
اذا في علاقه علاجيه
خاصه الطويله
تقريبا
يعني خطوره الانتحار عنده عاليه
ما في طريقه لتوقع الانتحار
في طريق لانه تقيم من درجه خطوره بس درجه
الخطوره
ارتباطها بحدوث الامتحان
[موسيقى]
يعني الى الان ما عندنا وسائل
يعني تمكننا من قراءه
اول ثلاثه شهور
شهرين ان هذه اول فتره العلاج
في الفتره في الفتره بتاعت العلاج ايا كان
استوائي علاج
ناجح في الكتاب الحاد
ايا كان نوع العلاج
مريض يتحسن
بشكل واضح للاخرين
بس في التجربه الذاتيه
تكون نشاطه اكثر
دافعيه
للقيام باي شيء اعلى
لكن حاسس ما زعل انه حياته ماساه
يرتفع نشاطه موجوده
اكثر القدره على النوم
يعني ينتحر
في فرق بين الناس اللي كنت في كندا
[موسيقى]
يعني انقطاع النفسي
لكن ما في فرق حقيقي في مشاكل
بس احنا ما عندنا هنا احصائيات
ولا حتى
كيف نقدر ندرس او نعالج فكره الانتحار
واحنا ما نعرف كم عددهم كيف الاطباء
الباحثين عفوا يقدرون يعني محاولات
الانتحار
الاطباء ما بشوفوا الامتحان
الانتحار تم
يمكن اشوف طبيب شرعي يقدر حتى لكن
الاطباء اللي بيعالجوا الناس بشوفوا
محاولات
في الرياض
في اشكاليه كبيره جدا في المجال
اشكاليه اللوجستيه
انه
ايش هي الجهه المسؤوله عن الوفاه اصلا
[موسيقى]
لو ما في الشارع قد تكون البلديه
البلدي المستشفى
بيحدد الجهه المسؤوله
وبعدين لو لو المساله فيها تحقيق لمعرفه
هل في عام الجنائي في الموضوع ولا لا
بتدخل فيها جهات امنيه
مثلا مره معقده
في ايش هي الجهه
المسؤوله فبالتالي
جمع الاحصاءات
لو ابتدينا اليوم بنحاوله تجميع الاحصاءات
من غير ما يكون في منظومه
يعني
مركزيه لحالات الوفاء
تنظم تداول المعلومات بشكل
صعوبه عالي
شهاده الوفاء
كذلك فيها مشاكل
[موسيقى]
المباشر قد يكون غير سبب الوفاه غير
المباشر
يعني
لو اخذ جرعه عاليه من دواء
سميته عاليه
السبب المباشر للوفاه توقف القلب والتنفس
كويس مهاره السبب المباشر لوفاه كل الناس
الطبيب الشرعي يقدر يعرف
كل الناس اللي بتموت في انهم وفاء
الاسباب المباشره مثلا مو شرط انها تديك
فكره عن
المسبب الحقيقي للوفاء خاصه
فلذلك
ما عندي فكره
عن درجه الشفافيه
عن حدوث الانتحار
واللي بنسمعه انه الشفافيه منخفضه جدا
يدخل الجنه الجنه
احم احم مش كده ولا لا
يعني فيها احس هذا الحساسيه
الامور حقيقه احنا محتاجين لمعرفه
المعلومات هذه لانه صعب انك انت تخطط
لخدمات من غير ما تكون عندك بيانات
البيانات دقيقه